which function has a local minimum with
a value of one has a local minimum with
a value of one so let's think about this
a little bit so they tell us the X
values and we see X increasing from
negative for all the way to positive 4
so our X values are increasing and they
give us different they give us different
functions here and they essentially say
where do which of these functions have a
local minimum value where the the value
of the minimum is 1 so they hit a
minimum point at one so that means that
the value of the function must be one at
that minimum point so let's see we can
see candidate points right over here f
of X hits one right over there G of X
hits one right over there and H of X
hits one right over there and let's see
that's the only time that they hit one
now let's think about which of these are
minimum values so on f of X when we go
from negative 2 to negative 1 we are
increasing from 0 to 1 and then we
increase again well that's not going to
be a minimum value we are increasing so
let me draw a little let me draw a
little axis right over here so let me
actually draw the whole thing just to
make it clear what we're doing so we
have negative 4 3 2 1 positive 1 2 3 4
and of course this is 0 negative 4
negative 3 negative 2 negative 1 1 2 3 4
and this is going to be 0 right over
here and we're going to care about
what's happening with what's happening
when these functions hit one so f of X
when X is equal to negative two is zero
when X is equal to negative 1 is 1 and
then when x is equal to 0 is 5 so 2 3 4
5 is that right over there and if we
assume that these are sampling from the
function we actually necessarily can't
make that assumption here but if we
assume that these are sampling then this
was a continuous function that we would
assume that the function does something
like this and so it's clearly not a
minimum point right over here we're
increasing into we're increasing into
div or increasing into one so this is
not a minimum point now let's look at G
of X let's see when G of X is one we're
at two when G of X is one we're at two
when G of X is a two-word one and when G
of X is 3 we're at negative 1 so we are
negative 1 so this is the opposite we do
decrease into that into that value when
the function hits one but then we keep
decreasing in order for this would be a
minimum point we would have to decrease
into it and then increase out of it so
this is all so this right over here is
also not a minimum point now let's look
at H of X when X is negative 4 we're at
five when X is at negative 3 we are at
one and when X is at negative 2 we go we
jump back up to 3 so this looks like a
minimum point we decreased going into it
and then we increased going out of it so
this is our local minimum point and if
this was a continuous function you and
maybe might look something like that so
we will go with H of X